♪♪
-Here's how it works.
We're gonna have
a number of mystery objects
brought out in front of us,
and our job is
to guess what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
We can never see
what's in the box.
-Okay. Oh, gosh.
-I know. I'm gonna freak out.
I thought I smelled an animal
backstage.
[ Laughter ]
I think I did.
-Was that you?
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Selena, since I'm
the host, I'll go first?
-Okay.
-Wait. What?
All right,
let's get to our first object.
Oh.
-Can I see what's...
-Yeah, you can see it,
but don't lie to me
and make it --
if it's crazier than it is.
[ Audience "Ohs", laughter ]
-Ha!
Go for it.
-Ah.
Here we go.
[ Inhales sharply ]
[ Cheering ]
-Oh.
-Oh. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
Go for it.
-No, but he said
something weird.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-Aah!
Gross!
-What the heck?
-Ooh!
Ew!
[ Laughter ]
It's -- uh, uh, a egg?
-Yeah.
-Egg?
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That was a lot.
-This is the first one.
It's kind of easy.
-You barely touched it.
-I touched it enough.
I touched it enough
to know what it was.
-Okay.
-It was --
I didn't like its viscosity.
-Okay.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
Oh.
Oh-ho-ho!
[ Audience screams ]
♪♪
-I feel like it's hair.
-Yes!
It is hair.
Oh, my -- Wow!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How did you --
You have guts, man.
-I don't even want to see it.
Just -- Just go away.
[ Laughter ]
That's so gross.
No!
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
My turn again.
Oh, no!
-[ Laughs ]
-I feel like the rounds
get crazier.
-Oh.
[ Cheering ]
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
♪♪
-I don't --
-Whoo!
[ Audience shouting ]
♪♪
-Yeah?
-No! I didn't feel anything.
I'm just freaking out.
[ Laughter ]
-You can do it!
-Gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
-Come on.
-All right.
♪♪
Aah!
[ Audience shouting ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Is it like a tongue
or something?
-Oh.
-Is it like a chicken
or a tongue or something?
-Nope.
It's a brain.
-Ew!
What the --
What?!
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
What in the what?
-Is it real?
No, it's not real.
-Is that a real brain?
-It's a cow brain.
-It was cow brain?
Get the Purell right now.
This is insane.
-Ew.
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with people?
Get this out of the way.
This is good.
All right.
The final round.
-Is this the final?
-Well, it is for me. Sure.
-Okay.
-That was
the final round right there.
Cow brain.
All right, this is up to you.
-What do I do?
[ Audience "Awws" ]
That's sad.
What do I do?
-All right,
you do the same thing.
-I do it?
-Yes, you do it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience screams ]
-Is it my dog?
No.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I don't know what the [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey! hey!
Come on.
-I'm sorry.
-It's a family show!
You see what you made her do?!
-I'm so sorry.
-You see what you made her do?!
You see what you made her do?
-Oh, that's so cute.
-Wait. I get cow brain,
and she gets a stuffed animal?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so sorry.
-Get this thing out of here.
I can't believe it.
-I'm sorry.
-All right, it's time
for the final round.
For this one, we're both
gonna get the same item.
The first person
to guess it wins.
-Okay.
-All right. Let's do this.
-Yep.
All right.
-All right.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
♪♪
[ Audience screams ]
-Do you smell that?
What?
It's, like, food.
♪♪
-Smells like...
[ Audience screams ]
-No.
♪♪
I think it's food
for, like, a duck.
No?
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
-What? What?
[ Buzzer ]
-It is so gross.
It's, like,
maggots or something.
-No!
-What are they?
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, my God.
-What were they?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-Those are mealworms.
Judges, who is the winner?
Audience, what do you think?
Who won?
-Selena!
[ Ding! ]
-Selena Gomez, champion.
Are you ready for this?
-I have one condition.
-Yes.
-No spiders.
-No, I can't guarantee
you anything.
No, I literally -- Last time,
they got me with them.
-I'll literally die.
-No, I know.
I can't even talk about it.
They did that to me last time.
-With spiders?
-Yes.
-Like, I'll -- I'll --
-I know, I'm freaking out.
I can't even talk to you now.
-No, no.
-I'm freaking out.
[ Laughter ]
Let's just go.
I'll go first.
I'll be the first one.
Let's get our first object.
-Okay, okay.
-Get this over with.
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm freaking out!
-Can I see what it is?
-Yes, you can see what it is.
-If this is crazy,
I'm gonna run.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
Why are you acting --
You're acting like
it's not anything.
Is it something?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Ew.
Ew!
It's, like, warm, it's slimy.
It's like something --
Ew!
It's, like, slime or something?
I don't like it at all.
Stop, stop, stop.
So gross.
What is it?
Dog food or something?
Ew! It's disgusting.
What is it?
-I hope mine --
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Mashed potatoes and gravy?
What did you think,
I was gonna put my hand
all the way into it?
Get this out of here.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Ew! Gosh!
All right, you're up.
No -- Oh, thank you.
-All right.
-What's going on?
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one told me about
this part of the game.
What is happening?
[ Laughter ]
It's way too much.
-Here, here.
-I have a hand full of Purell.
Yeah, I mean this all --
Okay.
-Okay.
-But now --
Yeah, now, I'm totally wet.
[ Laughter ]
Here we go, all right.
You ready for this?
-Okay.
-Good luck.
Kim, good luck.
You have 30 seconds.
-Just tell me if it's an animal,
people.
[ Laughter ]
Please.
♪♪
It's an animal.
-Stop, stop, stop.
-Okay.
-Don't look at anyone!
Don't! Stop it!
-Is it an animal?
-Stop it! Stop it!
Kim, stop!
-Wait. If it's an animal...
-Stop!
-Is it a spider?
Is it a spider?
-No!
-No? No.
-Aah!
-Silence.
I'm gonna do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're not scaring me.
Stop.
I don't feel anything.
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is it scary?
-No!
-Okay.
Oh, my God.
It feels like a stuffed animal?
[ Laughter ]
Is it a real animal?
-No, we'll give it to you.
It is a stuffed squirrel.
-Oh.
[ Dinging ]
Aah!
-No, it's a fake --
-Where is that hand sanitizer?
-We would never --
[ Laughter ]
-That is --
-Where's the hand sanitizer?
Please.
♪♪
-That's a real squirrel,
by the way, people.
-That was not a real squirrel.
-Yeah, I guarantee it.
-We would never --
No, it's a doll.
Aaah!
-Taxidermy.
-Here we go.
All right.
How many more of these
do I have to do?
Two more of these?
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Wah wah wah.
Come on, dude.
Man up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What are you talking about?
Don't even --
Stop it.
-I would die.
-Stop it, stop!
-Stop it. Seriously, guys,
don't freak out.
Guys, seriously,
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheering ]
I'm not doing my next one.
♪♪
-Waaah!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Whoo!
What was that?!
-If mine is like that,
I'm not doing that.
-Aaaaaaah!
Aaaaaah!
I hate it!
It was fuzzy!
It was -- what --
It was fuzzy.
And again, it was warm.
I don't like anything warm.
-Wait. Let me see something.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Aah.
Aaaaaah!
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my God!
[ Audience shouting ]
-Aaaaaah! Aaah!
It's a --
Oh, my God!
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe
you touched that.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Can we get the Purell?
-That's real.
[ Laughter ]
That is real.
-That was scary.
I'm so sorry, buddy.
Oh, my gosh.
That is real.
And, oh, my God, no.
All right, please.
-My -- The squirrel was real.
-No, it was not.
-Yeah, it was.
-Here we go.
All right, Kim, you're up.
-The squirrel was real.
You guys...
-Oh, gosh.
-If mine is like that,
I'm not doing it.
-No, I swear I would tell you.
-Okay, I'm looking at you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Am I okay?
-It's not --
-Is it an animal?
An animal?
-No, it's totally different.
-But I, like, smell an animal.
-No, you don't!
No, no.
Well, yeah, maybe --
maybe you do.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
-You got to go.
You got to go.
-Watch that hand.
Watch that hand.
Oh, my God.
Watch that hand!
-I'm okay?
Watch my fingernails?
-Watch your fingernails!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, okay, okay.
Is it an animal?
Just tell me.
Okay, okay.
[Bleep]
It's cold.
Aah!
What is it?
What --
Can I look?
It's slimy.
-Aaaaah!
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
-It was a frozen crab leg.
-I hate this game.
-I know, I hate this game, too.
Get this thing out of here.
We hate this game.
Please.
All right. It's almost done.
It's almost done, I swear.
-Another one?
-It's the last one.
This last one
is the final round.
For this one, we're both
gonna get the same item.
The first person
to guess it, wins.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
Come on.
We have to do it.
-I hate this game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have to do it.
Come on.
♪♪
We have to do it.
-What?
-I don't know, I don't know,
I don't know.
All right, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it an animal?
-No!
-Ready?
[ Both scream ]
Aah!
-[ Laughing ]
Come on, dude!
-Okay, we can do this.
Let's really focus.
Aah!
-Aah!
-The looks on their faces.
-Don't look at anybody!
Don't look at me!
♪♪
[ Both scream ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I felt hair.
-Don't touch it!
-Something touched me!
-I felt hair.
Is there, like, a wig?
[ Buzzer ]
Is it like a wig?
-I think it's a hand.
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
-How do you get in there, dude?
Oh, my God.
-Yoga.
-Since I'm the host,
I'm going to go first.
That's what it says on the card.
Why?
Oh, my gosh.
All right, let's get the object.
Why? Why?
-Can I look at what it is?
-Yeah, yeah.
You can look, yeah.
Ugh. Okay.
-Oh, okay.
-All right.
I don't know if you're -- if
that's your poker face or what.
All right, I'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
Here we go.
-Watch out there.
[ Laughter ]
-It's freaking me out.
It feels warm or something.
It's warm!
I don't like it, whatever it is.
It's really grossing me out.
This is so odd.
I can't even describe this.
I'm not looking at anyone.
Ah! Oh, God!
Oh, man, oh, man.
Can I just put my right hand?
-That's cheating.
You have to do both.
-Oh, gosh!
-Why not?
-Ah!
I hate this game so much!
I'm going to freak out
right now!
All right.
I'm doing it. Here we go.
Hey-o!
[ Audience cheering ]
Ah, ah, ah!
Ah, ah, ah, ah!
Shush! Shush, shush, please.
Shush, please. Shush.
Ah. Oh, my God.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh, it's marshmallow Peeps.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gosh, you guys are the worst!
You are all the worst people!
You were cringing.
You were like --
Oh, my gosh!
The worst!
My own audience turned on me!
Oh, my God!
Do not trust, especially her.
Oh, my gosh.
-That one?
-Yes. She was making faces.
Like, "Eh, don't touch it."
All right.
All right, Kate, you know we
would never do anything wrong
or rude to you,
so you have 30 seconds.
-Okay.
[ Audience groans ]
All right.
-They're not "oohing" that.
They're excited about --
We get to talk about
your new show, "The Widow."
It's going to be fun.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
We have a deal about
I can't touch vomit.
I'll touch poo if I have to.
-No.
I would never do that.
Really, I would
never ever, ever.
I would never do that.
-I'm phobic of --
-Aah!
-I don't like poo.
But I'm phobic of vomit.
And I'll go home.
-No, stop saying "poo"
and "vomit."
We're not doing either.
No, this is network television.
Here we go!
But you never know
what it might be.
Wait.
No poo?
-No, if I have to, I'll do poo.
But vomit, I'm going home.
-Well, then I think you'll
be close on this one.
-Is it poo?
[ Laughter ]
They wouldn't do poo to me,
would they?
-Not quite.
-Is it going to bite me?
Is it?
-You know,
I'm dabbing you right now.
I'm dabbing right now.
I'm so excited.
Just go for it.
-Stop it.
-Go for it.
Come on!
-Oh, God.
-Oh, no!
[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Why were they wet?
Ah!
It's sticky.
It's sticky and wet.
It's a poo.
It's a huge poo.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Is it?
You can grab it.
-Ooh, is this alive?
-No.
-Oh, wait a minute.
-Is it a cinnamon roll?
-Yes!
-Yeah!
-How did you guess that?
I love it.
[ Laughs ]
How did you guess that?
-Way to fake me out.
-I mean, it was good, right?
Yeah.
No, I would never do that.
To Kate Beckinsale,
are you kidding me?
Thank you.
My turn, unfortunately, again.
Ah!
All right.
Here we go.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Ah!
Come on.
Get in there.
-[ Breathing deeply ]
See, now the audience
is playing the game.
And I don't like it at all.
Whoo!
-Remember how lovely Peeps were.
Remember how lovely Peeps were.
He's just like this.
Oh, God.
-Ah! Is it moving?
Is it moving?
-No, but --
[ Laughs ]
-I'm freaking out, man.
Come on, dude.
-Yeah.
-Oh, gosh.
Freaking out right now.
All right.
Ah! Oh, my gosh.
I hate this game so much.
-This is slightly less
of an Easter theme.
♪♪
Oh, Jimmy.
[ Audience shouting ]
♪♪
-Is it poo?
It's a pile -- Ew.
Is it worms?
-Yes!
-Ew!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's bad.
-Get the [bleep] out of here.
-This is the worst game ever.
That was worms.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh!
-That wasn't good.
-Everyone knows I don't like
any of that stuff!
Aah! Yes, I need --
The Purell's not enough.
Oh, my God.
-Oh, God.
-Not a big deal.
I'm fine with worms.
Are you kidding me?
I'm like a total outdoorsman.
[ Laughter ]
All right, Kate, you're up.
It's can't be -- Come on,
it's got be easier than that.
Here we go. Yeah.
Here we go.
Aah!
[ Audience groans ]
No!
-No.
-Oh!
That lady in the mustard
yellow's made me scared.
Don't.
-Ohh.
-Do I wish it was poo?
-Oh.
-I wish it was poo.
Don't say that!
What?
Can you see it?
Can't see it.
[ Audience screams ]
Stop!
You guys.
Oh, don't!
It's so much scarier when
it's really you doing it.
[ Audience screams ]
Oh, stop!
Oh. Oh, what's that?
It's leathery.
Was it the underbelly
of something?
-Ohh.
-What is -- What is that?
What is that?
[ Audience screams ]
Did it move?
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah, time is up.
-I didn't know
there was a time limit.
I was gonna be here all day.
-It was a giant frog.
-No!
Was it really?
-Look at it.
Yeah, he's cute.
-Oh, God.
Oh, God.
-What did you think it was?
It was leathery.
-It was leathery.
I thought it was something's
underbelly, and it was.
-It was.
You were actually right.
Oh, this is the last round.
Thank goodness.
The final round.
-I'm light-headed.
-For this one, we're both
going to get the same item.
-At the same time?
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't like the view.
No, it's not good.
It's not a good sign.
-We're going to get
the same item.
The first person
to guess it wins.
-So we go in one side each?
-Yes.
[ Audience shouting ]
Ah!
[ Cymbals crash ]
-What was...
-I touched your hand.
Was it Jimmy's hand?
-Ah!
Ah!
[ Audience shouting ]
-Did you feel something?
-It felt warm or something.
-Warm?
-Yes.
Ah!
-It's alive. It's alive.
Aah!
It's a person.
It's a man!
-Ah!
-Is it a man?
-Is it a person?
-No, stop looking.
Is it a man?
Is it my stepdad?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he's moving around a lot.
It's a person.
-What is it, a hand?
-Who is that?
-That's a foot!
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Get the --
Where's the Purell now?
Yes.
-That was a foot.
Whose foot was that?
-I have no idea.
That was Tom Cruise's foot.
-Oh, phew.